what's going on guys this is rob and
despite having ran this channel for
about eight years one thing that we
haven't done is make a video explaining
doctor octopus
and i'm kind of astounded that we
haven't done that so we're gonna do it
here in this video i'm gonna make you
guys an expert on dr octopus in about 30
minutes or so the origin of dr octopus
is actually found in a few different
locations the most comprehensive origin
is actually found in dr octopus year one
which was really a multi-issue telling
of dr octopus's full origin but some of
the stuff that actually appears in
spider-man unlimited number 18 and
amazing spider-man issue number three
actually doesn't appear in doctor
octopus year one and so what we're gonna
do is we're gonna kind of combine these
three particular stories to form the
origin as we know it right so what we
know is that dr octopus was born in uh
in new york and basically had a abusive
father and a i wouldn't really say
loving mother more like an
overprotective and overbearing mother
right but she was in a lot of ways the
antithesis to the father of otto
octavius the reason why is because the
father of otto octavius really advocated
violence as a means to solve problems
now that was one of the things that stan
lee and and steve ditko and even jack
kirby and non-spider-man stories largely
focused on in these early days that
violence should be a last resort i
personally disagree i think violence is
not always the answer but it is a answer
and it's usually a very effective one
violence gets things done but at this
point in time that wasn't really the
philosophy it's one of the things that
actually made spider-man so popular is
that he would only ever fight if he
absolutely had to and so because of this
the the abusive nature of otto's father
was met in a couple different ways the
first was that he would always advocate
that otto used violence in dealing with
like bullies or anything like that and
the second is that he would actually
beat his son and so because of this the
antithesis to that was otto's mother who
always approached things from a much
gentler hand and so ultimately the
father of otto actually ended up dying
and uh and from there he had attended
mit and become one of his most
prestigious students actually graduating
at the top of his class now during his
whole time during the really the
motivation for attending mit and
becoming as intelligent as he was was
the philosophy of his mother which is
one that being a manual laborer is
nothing to celebrate right and that two
an early death is the result of a person
being a manual labor now we know that's
not the case
you know i shudder to think of a world
where we don't have masons or we don't
have plumbers right i mean those guys
are like a necessary part of society
right so because of that like we know
that's not necessarily the case but that
was the philosophy she held and a
philosophy she instilled in otto
octavius but the other part of this is
that in the absence of his father the
relationship between his mother and
himself became extremely important now
it didn't really approach anything in
the realm of impropriety but what it did
approach is this idea that otto octavius
really began to kind of live his life
based on his mother's standards and all
this really came to a head when he ended
up meeting a girl named mary anders now
the two of them fell in love they dated
they were head over heels they got
engaged but the mother of otto did not
like the idea of him having another
woman in his life because she felt like
nobody else was good enough and because
he was at this point living his life
based on his mother's standards he
ultimately broke off his engagement only
to find out that his mother was dating
somebody else and so he kind of came to
this or came out of it with a feeling of
betrayal that his mother's philosophy
was don't do as i do do as i say do
right but he felt as though he was his
own man he should be able to do his own
thing but the decision had already come
too late mary anders was already gone
she basically moved on to do her own
thing his mother had basically died of a
heart attack when he lashed out at her
after learning that she was in a
relationship with somebody else and so
all this did was really coalesce in the
mind of otto octavius bringing him to a
place where he had an extreme mental
struggles the anxiety and the stress
that came with graduating at the top of
his class at mit combined with the guilt
and the anger he felt you know basically
leading to his mother's death and and
the fact that she was dating somebody
behind his back or telling him you can't
have anybody but i can't right that kind
of a thing all that kind of come to a
head when he had found a job working at
the u.s atomic research center now this
basically had him developing what were
called his chest harnesses or his chest
tentacles if you want to call them that
it's the tentacles that you guys are the
most familiar with right the ones that
you control that do all kinds of
different things initially they were
they just existed based on simple
programming right i mean they were
developed by him and that was really it
but what ended up happening here is that
due to the mental struggles that he was
was suffering with this ultimately led
to him screwing up on the job making a
mistake and being splashed with
chemicals now the reason why this
happens this is something that i want to
clear up the reason why it was him being
splashed with chemicals as opposed to
you know some kind of just desire to
create these super advanced robotic arms
and just sort of going crazy of his own
of his own accord is because this was
the 1960s and we were already coming hot
off the heels of barry allen in 1956
over at dc comics when barry became the
flash right struck by lightning doused
in chemicals gained super speed and so
because of that kind of thing the
blending of science fiction and
superhero themes was really what saved
the comic book industry in the 1950s so
it was standard practice even going into
the 1960s to take this kind of science
fiction concept and apply it to comic
books it's the reason why peter parker
got his powers from a radioactive spider
as opposed to being you know receiving
magic at the hands of somebody like
doctor strange that gave him spider-man
powers it's the reason why the fantastic
four gain their powers from like cosmic
radiation as opposed to just scientific
advancement whatever the case says it
was all that kind of sci-fi stuff that
really led to the kind of formation of
the villains and even the superheroes
that we're familiar with today right the
important thing here is that after
making this mistake two things happen
the first is that instead of his arms
being controlled based on programming
that was created by by otto octavius he
could now mentally control them and the
second thing that happened is that he
had basically gone insane right that's
basically what it was right developed a
high level of narcissism and even really
sociopathy depending on who you're
talking to now that whole idea of him
becoming like an extreme narcissist a
megalomaniac that kind of a thing that
was just stan lee and jack kirby giving
us a motivation for why spider-man has
to fight him in the first place right
it's pretty simple relative to what you
see today but for the most part we just
kind of roll with it and just say okay
cool right it's a product of the time
and just kind of call it a day now what
ended up happening is that him
recovering he realized that given his
exceedingly high level of intelligence
his narcissism his megalomania all that
kind of stuff that he could actually
just initiate these massive campaigns
and possibly even conquer like huge
portions of society right that it
basically led him on this this gave him
this grandiose sense of self and so what
he started doing was actually kidnapping
and snatching up a whole bunch of lab
staff which ultimately led to him coming
into conflict with spider-man now that
was one of the major differences between
somebody like otto octavius and somebody
like the chameleon mysterio villains
that would come after auto octavius is
that unlike a lot of those guys that
otto overpowered peter parker like that
right it happened so fast he he defeated
him quite readily now that wasn't really
a result of otto octavius's intelligence
and powers it was to a degree but a lot
of it was also the way that peter parker
was written that peter was still
learning what it meant to be spider-man
as his stories were unfolding and so he
was still approaching different
situations from this idea that hey like
everything can be talked out he hadn't
quite learned the lesson that there are
some villains that while you never kill
them you just hammer on them with
overwhelming force as fast as you
possibly can and take them out as
quickly as you can right a lot of people
would probably argue the green goblin is
really when that started to shift up
that the green goblin is the one that
changed spider-man's perception
especially after the death of gwen stacy
now going into their second skirmish
peter parker came back and defeated dr
octopus with one punch and that was
really more of a development for peter
parker right that us as the the readers
of spider-man realizing spider-man was a
lot stronger than he thought he was and
indeed peter parker himself realizing he
was actually a lot stronger than he was
a lot of that went towards like you know
with great power must come great
responsibility so with that level of
strength must come an equal amount of
restraint to keep himself from just like
you know punching the head off of a
villain or beating somebody to death and
so that was a cool little development
for him but of course ultimately dr
octopus was was locked up now eventually
dr octopus came into contact with a guy
by the name of blocky gaxton now this
was a guy who was closely associated
with betty brandt the reality of this is
that this particular era in dr octopus's
life was really more development for
peter parker than it was for dr octopus
and the reason why i say this is because
blocky gaxton's involvement with with
betty brandt who of course at the time
was the girlfriend of peter parker was
really a result of betty's brother
bennett and the way this played out was
that betty and bennett had a mother who
had basically had you know extreme
medical bills and so bennett ended up
finding himself in a gambling debt with
blackie gaxton that he couldn't pay off
this ultimately led to bennett and betty
being kidnapped by blackie gaxton and
then dr octopus operating more as what
seemed to be a kind of hired hand than
anything else and ultimately spider-man
basically responded and so this led to
what was actually a fight between
spider-man and uh and doctor octopus as
well as a skirmish with blackie gaxton
during which time bennett brandt was
killed and so the result of this was
that it actually kind of gave us this
revelation on behalf of peter parker
that he couldn't save everybody and this
flew in the face of superhero themes as
we knew them right up until that point
in time superheroes pretty much always
saved everybody right it was just it was
the nature of things even in dc comics
iris west the wife of barry allen had
not been killed by eobard thon yet so we
hadn't really crossed that bridge of the
superhero the the tried and true
superhero being as popular as he was
being unable to save somebody right it
was a rule since since like superman and
lois lane it was a rule that like the
hero always came out on top he always
saved the innocent people this
development with peter parker was really
the first stage that really came to a
head with gwen stacy that he can't save
everybody so again that's why it was
more of a development for peter than it
really was dr octopus but ultimately uh
doc ock and blackie jackson end up
escaping so on and so forth and there's
a few little skirmishes here and there
right a few little things that take
place over the course of the ensuing
spider-man comics they ended up seeing
dr octopus facing off against peter
parker being defeated and then being
thrown in jail and so on and so forth
and this is where everything changed
when it came to doc ock and moved him
away from being a villain that was just
a typical guy who's got some kind of an
ability and wants to achieve some you
know megalo maniacal thing like
conquering the world and actually
elevated him into becoming one a more
relatable character and two one of the
most iconic villains of the spider-man
mythos this was the introduction of the
sinister six and the reason why this was
so important is because up to this point
in time by and large whenever you saw
villain groups that existed they had
come into existence by way of either
having previously existed in the first
place or a need or a desire or something
along those lines but it never really
came from a place of a villain admitting
they couldn't do it on their own and
that's what was going on with dr octopus
that that ottawa octavius would come to
this realization he couldn't defeat
spider-man by himself now on the
publishing side marvel did this because
it would sell like gangbusters right i
mean that's
there's no arguing that point right
that's why stan lee and them did this
because it would sell like crazy because
by the time the sinister six was invoked
you already had electro mysterio you
already had a lot of these villains that
were were mainstays for spider-man who
was already the most popular superhero
that marvel had running far and away
right that was there was there's no
arguing that during that at this point
in time spider-man was and really
remains to this day the single most
popular superhero that marvel has ever
and likely will ever create and so
gathering these different foes together
and then having dr octopus kidnap aunt
may as a way to bring in peter parker is
what kind of elevated the the role of dr
octopus because one he was the one who
was leading the group and two he's the
one that planned out how they were going
to win because the idea here was that
when he looked at peter parker facing
off against various members of his
rogues gallery he came to the
realization that it was usually always
peter parker leading them to a place
where peter parker would have a better
chance of defeating them what the
sinister six did is they flipped it on
its head and they said we're going to
bring peter parker to a place where we
are most likely to win right so that's
why each member of the sinister six
fought spider-man in a place that was
the most conducive to the nature of
their powers now of course again kind of
working and building up on spider-man a
little bit again i don't want to turn
this into like a kind of spider-man
explained but it is pretty important
here one of the things that was
established was that even in the face of
seemingly overwhelming defeat spider-man
seemed to still be able to find a way to
win but for the development of doctor
octopus one of the things that was so
intriguing here was that unlike a lot of
villains that were out there that would
kill whoever they needed to kill or do
whatever they needed to do in order to
win that he actually never mistreated
aunt may and in fact aunt may loved
hanging out with dr octopus because he
was so uh so charming when it came to
her we know he was manipulative but he
was also extremely charming and treated
her incredibly well and so that kind of
changed a lot of the viewer perception
of doc ock moving him away from being a
guy who was just this villain of the
week to a guy who's kind of like hey
like there's a little more to this guy
than we them then we're really familiar
with now one of the interesting things
here is that when it came to dr octopus
even after this right the sinister six
just elevated him and made him
exceedingly popular unlike what you saw
with a lot of villains who were out
there right different writers taking
over the handling of spider-man a lot of
the spider-man comics just you know just
spitting out into even more comics to
the point that it was almost just an
unruly roster of spider-man comics it
was ridiculously hard to follow
everybody seemed to nail dr octopus
right i have yet to discover an instance
where dr octopus in these early days had
what you would call a bad story most of
these early stories i absolutely love
now most all of them saw him fighting
against peter parker and ultimately
being defeated by spider-man but more so
than that it actually saw dr octopus
doing things like taking over the role
that was left vacant by the kingpin
wilson fisk after he had left the united
states following the death of vanessa as
well as going to war with a lot of the
other members of spider-man rogues
gallery or even other members of the
criminal underworld for the purpose of
just consolidating power these are
usually always in in spider-man
defeating him but ultimately you saw
some great moments here one of the more
interesting things that happened during
this time in dr octopus's history
actually ended up coming from amazing
spider-man issue number 397. now one of
the things about this is that dr octopus
had a at least a kind of relationship
with a girl named mary alice who was
ultimately dying the idea of doctor
octopus was to search for a cure to
basically end up saving her right but
during the time spider-man was also
dying as well and so what dr octopus had
done in kind of an honorable moment here
although not really honorable per se
because he wanted to be the one to kill
spider-man he actually ended up creating
a cure for peter parker that would
ultimately save him so in effect this
villain ended up saving his own
character's life now the reason why this
mattered was really because of the fact
that dr octopus had really come into
contact with a lot of of what you would
consider to be some of the more brutal
villains or anti-heroes in marvel the
punisher people like black cat things
along those lines he had fought a lot of
these guys and it was one of these cool
things because you actually go back and
you look at fantastic four number 267
and you actually find out that the
doctor octopus was supposedly suffering
from multiple personality disorder as he
was diagnosed by by mr fantastic but his
involvement in secret wars the fact that
he was one of the most notable villains
uh that was brought along in this
particular storyline it was things like
this that made the comics so interesting
and so intriguing when it came to the
function the form and function of doctor
octopus in marvel comics but despite how
great a lot of these early stories were
and you start getting into the 1990s
particularly in 1994 where you kind of
struggle with liking some of the stories
that dr octopus had
particularly in spectacular spider-man
221 when he was killed by kane now
following that and going into uh the
amazing spider-man 426-428
you actually end up having him creating
his own kind of assassin technically
once he's dead like carol traynor ends
up kind of becoming the new doctor
octopus which didn't really receive a
lot of fanfare dr octopus himself is
actually resurrected by the hand and
then there's a couple of skirmishes in
between and then ultimately he tries to
create his own assassin out of uh out of
charlotte wit which is not the most
interesting thing ever but it was stuff
like that that was kind of like
you know i don't i don't know if i can
really get behind that
the reality of this and and really from
my perspective dr octopus really from i
would say the the mid 90s for about 10
years wasn't really all that interesting
and instead he got interesting during
the events of civil war now civil war
was a really really cool concept when it
came to doctor octopus because one of
the things that had happened during that
story is most of you guys know either
from our coverage of it or having read
it on your own is that uh is that peter
parker had basically unmasked himself
and revealed to the world his identity
as peter parker as kind of a
demonstration that he trusted in the
superhuman registration act as it had
been put forward by iron man now the
funny thing about this is that even back
in the early amazing spider-man stories
that doctor octopus had actually
unmasked peter parker but refused to
believe that it actually was peter
parker instead he just saw him as just
being some kid and that he was
ultimately looking for quote unquote the
real spider-man the revelation in this
was designed to kind of build on that by
establishing that peter parker was
actually spider-man like it really was
him and that ultimately dr octopus had
become pissed off and angry over the
fact that peter parker this teenage kid
had managed to defeat him so many times
before now a lot of the things that have
kind of gone on here between like the
sinister six the idea that uh that that
aunt may have been kidnapped by dr
octopus because he knew peter parker's
identity as spider-man that had been
wiped away by this point in time right
that had been basically removed from the
picture and a lot of dr octopus's
memories of those selective events had
been taken away following his
resurrection by the hand it was a way
for marvel to kind of undo the fact that
dr octopus knew who peter parker was and
to a degree kind of start with a bit of
a fresh slate not a wholly fresh slate
but you know a little able to kind of
rework the landscape to a degree but
ultimately despite his rampage and being
pissed off that peter parker is actually
spider-man and you know trying to be
part of the thunderbolts and all that
kind of stuff he's ultimately arrested
by shield and thunderbolts issues 104
through 109 over the course of that
story arc and depending on who you talk
to and i'm really in this crowd this is
when you probably got dr octopus at his
absolute most interesting right so the
way this played out is it was all really
part of an ongoing story written by a
guy named dan slott which really kicked
off with spider-man big time whenever
anybody asked me i want to start reading
spider-man where should i start i
usually say big time uh sal over at
comedypop was the one who gave me that
advice and i followed it and it had been
a lifesaver right that guy knows more
about spider-man than seemingly anybody
that i've ever met over the course of my
life but uh the cool thing about this is
the way dan slott wrote this was that
after everything that had happened with
dr octopus over the course of his life
the injuries he'd sustained all that
kind of stuff that he was in effect
dying the funny thing is that he had set
plans in motion to ensure that he would
survive but the funny thing here is that
all these plans that he had set up his
body breaking down and literally just
kind of falling apart all that was a
backstory to what was happening in
spider-man big time right during the
events of like spider island really more
dance slots run than big time but during
spider island and all that kind of stuff
all those things that were going on
everything happening here was happening
in the background but over the course of
those background stories you actually
ended up learning that what dr octopus
had done is he had put a portion of his
consciousness inside a little kind of
device which it ultimately latched
itself to the body of peter parker and
that when the time was right which
ultimately took place in spider-man
issue number 700 that dr octopus had
full-on taken over the the body of peter
parker and peter parker himself was just
kind of a consciousness fragment that
was left and then ultimately ended up
dying off and so what this did is it
basically removed peter parker
physically from the landscape of marvel
comics and replaced him during what is
probably one of the more interesting
runs of spider-man probably one of the
best runs of spider-man which we call
superior spider-man which is basically
when dr octopus takes over the body of
peter parker it was a great story at the
time that story came out a lot of
spider-man fans called doom and gloom
right they were like this like marvel's
gonna kill spider-man they're gonna
destroy interest in spider-man forever
superior spider-man was actually pretty
well received a lot of people really
really liked it i loved it but one of
the reasons why the story was so great
is that it focused on the development of
dr octopus in the sense that up until
that point in time he had kind of lived
within this these sort of confines of
what you would expect a villain to be
despite the fact that he broke some of
the boundaries of what villains normally
are insofar as him like waging war
against the criminal underworld trying
to consolidate all that power unto
himself which was not something that you
normally saw among spider-man villains
even if you saw it with other villains
like kingpin or something along those
lines at the end of the day he was still
a tried and true villain in marvel in
the traditional sense with a few small
gleaming instances where he defied that
standard over the course of superior
spider-man it changed everything because
he starts learning these small little
lessons about what it means to actually
be spider-man one of the first things
that happens here is he actually ends up
getting a fight with matt gargan the
scorpion and during that conflict
punches his jaw off of his face and
that's when he realizes spider-man had
been pulling his punches all this time
one of the other things that he also
ends up realizing is that peter parker
is highly intelligent but just seems
undisciplined and so one of the things
that takes place here is that over the
course of the comic doctor octopus
actually starts moving away from being a
villain as you would expect especially
when it came to anna marconi the one
that kind of helped him to sort of
redeem himself become a good guy and
actually starts becoming a good guy now
in the middle of superior spider-man you
did get the whole spider-verse story
right which was a little bit of a a kind
of added benefit to superior spider-man
because what dr octopus had to come to
grips with is that during the
spider-verse event he ended up coming
into contact with a future version of
spider-man from the main marvel universe
who is peter parker so it basically
solidified that peter was going to get
his body back at some point in time but
between the lessons he'd learned
alongside anna the lessons he'd learned
being a superhero what he actually
started doing was working on something
great and so we actually started
developing uh parker industries and the
whole idea was to literally take all the
technology that peter parker had used as
spider-man and enhance it right make it
better he also started doing things like
developing his own technology that could
make him a more effective spider-man
this was great it was absolutely
fantastic now the funny thing is that at
this point in time we've talked about
this a lot in previous videos marvel was
basically winding down a lot of their
story arcs and they were heading in the
direction of secret wars in 2015 right
the multiversal collapse and it seemed
as though marvel was rebooting or really
uh really marketing it as a potential
reboot for the entirety of the marvel
universe where everything was gonna be
restarted from zero in hindsight i guess
that's not really true there wasn't
really anything they said that it's
going to be a reboot but they also
didn't say it was going to be a reboot
so i guess they were kind of playing
both sides in that instance but
regardless of how you how you look at it
what you ended up seeing is that at the
end of superior spider-man that peter
parker got his body back and ultimately
he was actually grateful for the stuff
that dr octopus had done the development
of parker industries right creating you
know using parker industries as one part
think tank one part charitable
organization and so while you only got a
couple of story arcs right about 12
issues for amazing spiderman when peter
parker came back that goes into secret
wars 2015 and then you go into all new
all different marvel now the funny thing
here is that you know in the aftermath
of superior spider-man and all that kind
of stuff that you ended up having a
doctor octopus who had basically taken
over the body of a robot basically and
just kind of lived with inside this this
robot and largely operated in the
background right there really wasn't a
whole lot that he had going on there but
the notion of the living brain was a
cool concept because it gave us this
idea that dr octopus was almost in the
same capacity as iron man a futurist
right looking to the horizon looking to
the future and he's always kind of one
step ahead of everybody else in terms of
his intelligence the way this had played
out is that when it came to him
developing this kind of machine body for
himself he had actually used technology
from the uh from the future of miguel
o'hara right spider-man 2099 he had used
technology from that era brought it back
to the modern day and then literally
places consciousness inside of it
because he knew that once he once peter
parker had gotten his body back the only
body left for dr octopus was his dead
body right the one that was basically
dying and so knowing that he was gonna
die he essentially backed himself up and
then just kind of continued on now the
idea of him being confined inside this
body went all the way up into the events
of a clone conspiracy now clone
conspiracy was a great story a lot of us
were really concerned it was going to be
like clone saga which was a terrible
story in the 1990s but clone conspiracy
basically dealt with the jackal uh who
was literally going around right miles
warren was going around and basically
resurrecting people using clones giving
them new bodies different things along
those lines in a bid to mass power
during the end of the story what dr
octopus had done is that actually been
giving himself a new body that was by
all standards of measurement a clone of
spider-man and then went forward as
superior spider-man yet again this time
facing out on the west coast but unlike
previous spider-man stories it was
really a continuation of what we had
seen happen with superior spider-man
where he wasn't really going out and
doing villainous things instead he was
largely fighting as what you would
expect a hero to be now despite how
interesting the new superior spider-man
comic was and having idol octavius
fighting out in san francisco as what
was basically spider-man west coast at
the end of the day it didn't last and
that was for a couple different reasons
the first was because the comics just
weren't selling all that well and it
kind of made sense superior spider-man
if i'm being honest really only ever
should have been a particular comic book
run and never should have been
maintained for the long term but it was
so popular that marvel took a shot at it
and it just didn't quite get the
reception they were hoping for the other
part of this is that dr octopus as the
guy with the tentacles and the
megalomania and the villain of
spider-man is his most iconic form and
that's really what people wanted to see
and so what you ended up getting at the
conclusion of superior spider-man was
basically a deal that was made with
mephisto where doctor octopus would go
back to being his villain himself in
response to gaining the power to defeat
a version of spider-man from earth
44-145 who was basically norman osborne
due to everything that had popped off
with a second conflict with the
inheritors and all that kind of stuff
right spider-verse two and that's what
you want to call it wasn't nearly as
good as the first one but uh because of
the the conflict between the two this
led to uh you know dr octopus basically
accepting the deal of mephisto now in
reality this was beautifully handled it
was really cool because if you would
follow the story of dr octopus even if
you only started in superior spider-man
and you knew enough about him to
understand the significance of him
becoming you know spider-man and the
kind of change of character that he
experienced then seeing it all basically
come to a head uh during the during the
ending of superior spider-man vol 2 was
pretty devastating because he had
basically thrown away all the progress
that he'd made the nature of the deal
was such though that he had basically
lost all his memories as peter parker
and kind of gone back to dr octopus as
he existed right before the events or
really during the events of the first uh
spider-verse event so he was basically
dr octopus as as you know classic
octopus as you remember him right and
just went back to his life of villainy
and in reality i do welcome kind of the
reaching the the return to the status
quo i mean at the end of the day anybody
who's been reading comics for any real
measure of time knew that was coming but
at the same time it's also a little
bittersweet because the progress of him
becoming a good guy over the course of
the superior spider-man stories was
fantastic right it was so cool but at
the moment right now things are still
unplaying in the sinister war as is
taking place in uh in in the spider-man
comics which we actually need to cover
because sinister war is really really
cool we really need to get caught back
up again on spider-man but nonetheless
you know at this moment right now dr
octopuses back to his old self doing his
old self stuff right so uh with that
being said guys hopefully this teaches
you everything you need to know about
doctor octopus again we kind of had to
skim over a lot of the finer points
there's a lot to cover here we're
literally talking about a guy who's been
around since like 1964. uh there's just
a lot there's just too much history to
cover in a single video so i do have a
podcast idea and maybe we'll do it with
this one right where i basically make
like an hour-long podcast that does like
a far more in-depth comprehensive
explanation about characters than what
we do here because even as long form as
this is sometimes it's just not long
enough but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end thank
you guys for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace